over the past few weeks, as you
know, a number of Western countries have made
illegitimate decisions on the so-called
freezing of Russian assets,
and this collective West has actually
drawn a line under the reliability of its currencies
.  natural gas transfer payment for
our natural gas supplied to the so
-called non-friendly countries for
Russian rubles,
while I want to separately emphasize that
Russia will continue to unconditionally supply
natural gas in accordance with the volumes
and at prices according to the pricing principles
fixed in your earlier
contracts, the changes will affect only the
payment currency, which will be  changed to
Russian rubles I ask the government
to give an appropriate directive to Gazprom
on amending existing
contracts I ask the Bank of Russia, together with the
government, to determine within a week the
procedure for such transactions
to  when they impose sanctions on the supply of
spare parts for an aircraft when they
take away an aircraft it
is directly related to the health of people with
threats to their lives, it doesn’t matter when the
reserves of the central bank are very no
one could predict what
sanctions my for this is just a geek with
theft I dare to assure you and
the president of the government
work within the
framework of the Russian economic union
is constantly paying attention to this, and within the framework of the CIS there are free trade zones,
these issues are also
being considered, we will do everything so that
our
integration movement forward does not
suffer